[Music]
thank you
I just dropped off Marcia at the
hospital we think tomorrow it will
happen so she's gonna stay overnight and
tomorrow will be a dad I'm very nervous
I'm nervous for Marzia but I know she's
gonna do super well I know she's really
good at this kind of thing she's always
a bit scared but I know I know she can
totally handle it really well yeah I
feel bad I'm leaving her alone but I
will be there hopefully when Bjorn is
born I'm just gonna hang with the
puggies for the time being
and she's gonna let me know how he goes
in the hospital it's such a strange day
because
obviously we had uh nine ten months now
leading up to it but you just can't I
just can't imagine like there's gonna be
a baby
like I've thought about it hundreds
thousands of times and but it's just
like I can't imagine it's gonna be a
baby like I don't know I have no
experience to relate that to so it's
also new uh so it's very exciting to say
the least but come on emergency you got
this
foreign
[Music]
it's hot everyone just goes it's harder
where I am it's way harder where are you
41 degrees in humidity is bad
it's so disgusting to be outside
even for a sec I my top of my head is
cooking I was out for like a minute I
hope they have AC at the hospital for
emergency otherwise
[Music]
ah
it's now 5 30. the doctor woke up March
at five I looked destroyed look at me
and I called Martin she looks so
beautiful and perfect she's having more
contractions now and stronger
contractions so I think any point today
I'll get the call to get over there when
it's time for to deliver the baby but I
think it really is happening today
everything's looking great Martha's
doing amazing I'm gonna give
these sleepy guys a little walk before
it gets too hot out because it's super
early anyway today's the day
let's go guys
I just had a nap Mars has been at the
hospital for almost 24 hours now her
body's 100 ready I it's hard to
understand but I think he's laying in a
position that kind of blocks him from
coming out uh or dropping down rather
right now Marissa is sitting in a in a
pose that will hopefully make him move
if that doesn't work she will have to do
a C-section
what she's fine with and obviously yeah
I'm fine with obviously too I'm
C-section and it just kind of feels like
she's gone through so much to get her
body to this to be fully ready and now
she is ready but it's like she can't
because yeah so I hope that this pose
will work uh and if not
no BC section
so no matter what he's coming out today
you have no choice Baron
apparently there was a bit of a scare
while I took a nap it's all fine now so
that's good and I'm kind of glad I slept
through it
I feel bad like my sister's been in the
hospital for so long and I'm just here
we're obviously talking on the phone but
just chilling with you Iggy the best net
buddy of all time so yeah I'm heading to
the hospital pretty soon as soon as I
get the call I think within an hour at
least it's very exciting what a crazy
experience I can't imagine what it's
like for Marzia I'm just like I said I'm
just here
all right this is it Bjorn moved he's he
went in the right position I'm just
waiting to be called into the hospital
and my time is limited there
freaking out
yeah I just hope she's okay
I'm freaking out
[Music]
thank you
oh he's so happy with you
[Music]
Karen is born I don't want great he's so
cute I am officially a Dan so strange I
have to go now because I was only in
line for uh two hours and a half
actually they extended a little bit
myself was feeling a little sick
afterwards she has a bit of a fever she
lost a lot of blood but everything went
really well beyond this great mine says
doing
doing well I'm just very happy at all
and thankful it all went so well
unfortunately I have to go back
but I will visit them tomorrow and we'll
talk over phone
[Music]
oh
they had a beard everyone
yeah
hello
I might say it was the biggest Warrior
on the planet that was such a long labor
and look what you we make
huh best thing ever
hmm
I'm back home I am so tired I can't
imagine Marzia and it hasn't even
started yet first day and I'm already so
tired
but beyond seems really chill I don't
remember if I talked about the delivery
but it all went really well Martin said
did amazing seriously she was such a
such a champion it was so nice when I
came in and I got to see her and we were
both so happy
and then
she had already been pushing a little
bit so I came in for the last bit and
then he was born today I got to spend
more time with him which was really good
it felt so weird that's just like
leaving him but I'm glad I got to spend
time with him today and we change his
diaper and fed him and stuff like that
so it really felt like
oh this is my baby a lot more so he's
coming home in two days uh because
marziah needs to recover and
stay with yarn and I'm not allowed to
stay more than two hours so I have no
right of saying I'm tired like I might
say it's just gone through so much and
she still has to look after Brian the
nurses are helping a lot obviously the
name is Bjorn which is an old uh Viking
name I always really like the name yarn
even as a kid I thought it was such a
cool name it means uh bear in Swedish
and I remember as a kid I was like you
could be named that that's so cool so I
I think it's a really fitting name it
kind of works in Japanese too like Bjorn
it's not too strange and there's a
really big popular baby brand ins it's
Swedish obviously baby Byron
so people recognize it from there even
here so that's good and uh he's so cute
I think it fits in perfectly it's a soft
and hardening so yeah it's pronounced
Bjorn like uh it's kind of it's a it's
usually hard for foreigners to say that
word letter I mean
usually people say Bjorn like an O but
it's a uh like yarn
I don't know how to explain how to say
it better than that it's only nine but
I'm going to bed I'm just so tired I'm
gonna feed you guys and then we'll go
upstairs huh what do you say
you missing Marzia should be home soon
I set this up for Martin beard because
tomorrow they're coming home
I don't know I thought it was cute
and apparently it's a tradition in Italy
so Marissa's parents sent us very nice
to put up
one of these if there's a new baby he
put up one of these on your door
so I'm gonna do that
and tomorrow they're coming home it'll
be the first time that we get to film
what it feels like to be parents so
a little nervous but I think it's gonna
go well
today's the day I've sat so many times
outside the hospital waiting and I
always see so many mothers coming out
with their babies but today it is our
day to do that I almost thought like oh
we have such a long journey ahead and
it's gonna be so difficult
I mean it just started started really
but
we did it jiren is here and we get to go
home I'm very very happy
what a weird smelling die
[Music]
check this out this has been here for
nine months
and my little 3D cat
so you paint one eye before you have a
wish and then you paint the other eye
when the wish is completed I don't know
exactly if that's what it is it's a
DaRuMa but it's time to paint the eye
and then we burn it at New Year's
I never completed one before
that was a terrible eye
sorry during my son
[Music]
we survived our first night Masa stayed
up so late
I didn't even realize so she's still
asleep and I'm trying to take care of
him as much as I can this morning
you pooped a lot last night you sprayed
all over proud of you it was like 4 AM
or 5 A.M
I'm feeding Bjorn and then I drop one of
the glass bottles and he gets on the
floor and the dogs run over it and Bjorn
is crying because he wants milk and is
like oh God
I can already feel the chaos but I think
we're doing good he's fine he sleeps a
lot he seems happy as long as he gets
milk
which seems to be the time soon
[Laughter]
oh
how did that happen homie you got it
get off me woman
[Music]
you're supposed to keep him out a little
bit but he didn't like it's too bright
for you huh
or if I cover a little bit
[Music]
emergency made cupcakes
would you like one
um
oh
so good fresh
love it you're not supposed to do
housework
we're on our third day
taking care of the little one I feel a
lot less tired today can only improve
from here the sleeve is the worst part
really it's easier to take care of
he just poops and piss poops and eats
and sleeps
this is not a bad life
we're gonna give him a little Stampy
yeah yeah
[Music]
just wanted to show our baby sleeping
so cute
nice hair my dude where's Mommy doing to
you there you go
oh so proper
foreign
[Music]
sleepy boy here it's been about three
weeks
since he was born
being a dad has been
um I don't think anyone says it's easy
in a lot of ways it has been easier than
I thought because he's just been
sleeping pooping
pooping some more and then eating then
pooping again and he likes to do it
right after I change his diaper don't
you yarn
but I think myanmars have been doing
really well I'm really proud of how well
we work together and
uh could do with a little bit more sleep
though piano is very cute as you can
tell
I think he looks just like me like
looking at all the photos of myself and
comparing to Byron it's almost creepy
sometimes I look at him I'm like did I
clone myself
this is some weird sci-fi movie
and then you're like oh yeah that's how
babies work he's got mice's hair color
though so much hair man it's been really
cozy mainly just been
reading playing video games working out
we've been advised here in Japan you're
not supposed to bring your baby out for
a month but it's been two he's pooping
it's been too uh hot and the Sun is too
strong anyway well we can soon take him
out which will be fun
I can't wait to leave the house I I mean
I have been but we're eager to you know
do stuff
with you being aren't you too and
hopefully we can share some of that as
well and uh
[Music]
just want to say um I really appreciate
everyone being so nice and just happy
for us
it feels amazing that
so many people feel that way and I'm so
happy everything went well
obviously and Beyond is doing great I
couldn't ask for more really so well
some more sleep would be nice
but yeah that's the end of the Vlog and
yeah
say hi to Baron I guess who once
what can I do for you
yeah
bien says hi back
all right
foreign